hello everyone
this video is meant for the students who
have taken a drop for JE
I am a faculty at IIT kharagpur in the
mechanical engineering department but
when I was your age I was myself a
dropper so the things that I'm going to
discuss in this video are based on my
personal experiences and my hope is that
you're going to benefit from some of
them
I only wish that somebody had told me
this just I'm just as I'm going to tell
you now back when I was your age
I just had to figure these things out on
my own
so in this video first of all I'm going
to discuss four important tips but the
fifth thing that I'm going to discuss is
not a tip it's going to be a scolding
you heard that right it's going to be a
scolding
all right first of all the the one of
the most important tips is that you have
to understand that for the sake of je
you have to go about
leveling up step by step
what I mean by that is that 4J Advanced
so when you are preparing for JE many of
you start with the notion that you are
going to be appearing for JE Advanced
but the issue is that there are certain
very special kinds of problems in J
Advanced which require a special kind of
advanced preparation
now if you start your preparation from
that level instead of building up very
foundationally step by step making sure
that you are confident that each and
every subsequent step
first of all your foundation is going to
be very flimsy and weak
and even if you can maybe accidentally
solve a couple of problems at the GE
advanced level
what is going to happen is that
you may not be able to perform well in
je Mains or maybe some of the other
state level or other entrance
examinations now in the drop year it is
extremely important for you to
understand that this is the last chance
so you have to actually ensure that you
get through James or some other entrance
examination to end up in a very good
college
this is extremely extremely important to
understand so you start up you start
with a with the kind of preparation
which will automatically ensure a backup
plan you cannot start preparing
for a level which will kind of give you
the dream and the hope and the
aspiration of getting into an older IIT
and then later on think about some kind
of a backup plan no your backup plan has
to start foundationally and later on you
can go for a more aspirational goal of a
higher level performance that will get
you into the iits this is extremely
extremely important to understand
what I so let me give you a very
specific example regarding this
uh suppose
let's consider the case of organic
chemistry now we know that 4J Advanced
reaction mechanisms are very important
topic
now maybe in some of the Lower Level
examinations entries examination
reaction mechanisms are not that
important
but if you just think of preparing for
reaction mechanisms without even
ensuring that you are absolutely
confident with maybe conversions organic
chemistry conversions then your
preparation is very flimsy what are you
doing
okay and for this uh I'll I'll say this
that
if necessary you have to make sure that
the board level kind of thing is
something which you are absolutely
confident about suppose you have to sit
for your board exams hypothetically
speaking again then uh you would
absolutely come out with flying colors
so somebody who is thinking of going for
an interest examination like Jay should
be absolutely absolutely confident with
the board level stuff okay so before you
can go to the higher level make sure
that you absolutely are confident with
the lower level stuff okay so if you are
real if your preparation has been solid
it should be that you will absolutely
sail through these state level entrance
examinations the je Mains okay if your
real if your preparation for J Advanced
has been truly genuine then that should
be the case Okay so every step has to be
concretely fulfilled
next
there is a tendency among some students
so this is the next step there's a
tendency among some students to spend an
undue amount of time on certain topics
what I mean by that is there are certain
students who develop a certain level of
proficiency in Mastery in a certain
topic now there is a great Temptation
among them
to spend a lot of time just doing
difficult difficult problems in that
very narrow topic they will find out
from various sources difficult questions
and keep on spending a lot of time uh
just dealing with those kinds of
problems but not realizing that the time
that they are spending on one very
narrow topic ultimately there may be
only a very limited marks from that
topic so what what I mean what's the
benefit of being able to very
confidently do one problem or two
problems from a very narrow Topic at the
level of je Advanced or maybe even
Olympiad level problem if
your overall preparation is not very
good so if you cannot solve very basic
kind of problems from other topics and
uh so maybe even from the state level
interest examination then then what is
the benefit and mind you for J Advanced
it is quite often the case that
the questions are kind of composite
problems
combining Concepts in one single problem
from various chapters so just because
you are a master in one chapter doesn't
necessarily ensure actually that you are
going to end up performing very well so
your Mastery should be spread across all
the chapters covering the entire
syllabus
maybe in one or two topic naturally you
are going to end up being strong so
practice in that but don't spend an
undue amount in that I have actually
seen this kind of uh of a of a behavior
in certain students they fall into this
trap of uh
of just practicing problems from a very
narrow domain from a very narrow set of
topics so I can understand the
Temptation and and the problem here is
that it gives you a sense of and
actually this is a false sense of
achievement okay you think that yes I
can do maybe J advanced level problems
or maybe very difficult problems from
different sources but this is not real
preparation
so you have to guard yourself against
this kind of a temptation
your preparation should be uh broad
enough so that you can perform well in
all the topics
the next topics regarding coaching
so see in your drop year the foremost
thing which you have to understand for
yourself is what are the topics in which
you are weak
okay this directly connects with the
previous tip that I had discussed
just like it is important for you to
understand the strong points it is also
important for you to understand what are
your weak points because it is because
of those weak points that you were not
successful in your first attempt
now if you are joining some kind of a
coaching Institute then it is highly
likely that the coaching Institute
teachers are going to teach you not like
a private tutor but as part of a large
batch and as part of that large batch
they are going to have a certain agenda
a certain schedule of their own and they
may be starting uh maybe the first three
months on certain topics on which you
are already familiar and comfortable so
is it not a waste of time for you to not
devote those three initial months on
topics which you actually should be
preparing on which you are actually weak
so what otherwise is the benefit of you
taking the drop you taking the drop is
basically like the the bear truth is
this that you taking the drop is just
giving yourself extra time for
Preparation now if you spend that extra
time in doing things which you already
know just because the coaching Institute
teacher is teaching you you are actually
I mean
I mean you are just harming yourself
okay so don't do that the extra time
that you have given yourself by
sacrificing one year utilize that time
to actually cover up the defeats the
loopholes in your preparations the
Lacuna in your preparation okay I mean
this is so very obvious I simply cannot
understand why people do not realize
this okay this is the most obvious thing
do not
let yourself be guided by someone else's
agenda or someone else's schedule you
have to understand what are your weak
points what are the things you need to
study study those it's so very obvious
Okay so
uh
I said I'll give you a scolding at the
end but here is this quilting okay don't
do this okay this is this is just stupid
please don't do this
okay the the next Point uh so this is
something negative associated with uh
with the coaching institutes but uh
there is something positive with
coaching institutes also which is my
next point
and that is uh the big help that
coaching institutes provides uh in in
the in the form of mock test so this is
very very important in my drop here this
is if there is one correct thing that I
did during my uh drop year was that how
I dealt with the mock test and I gave
dozens and dozens okay maybe almost a
hundred mock tests during my drop year
so this is again a very simple like a
very obvious strategy but I do not
understand why many people do not
realize this this is see when you when
you give a mock test okay
uh of course you are not going to be
able to solve everything so when you
don't understand something when you are
missing a question after the test is
over you have to make sure that you go
through the solutions of all the
problems if you do not understand
anything you have to go back and study
them re-study the concept until and
unless you can grasp the concept so very
well that the next time such a question
comes from the same concept in the same
topic there is no way you are going to
miss that okay this is a very very
simple and obvious thing
once you face a hurdle once you stumble
on something make sure that is no longer
a stumble in future
okay so this was a massive mistake which
I made during my first attempt I I did
give mock test that time also in my
first attempt but I never took out the
time or the effort to actually learn
from my mistakes
so I mean moctas are definitely good to
give you an idea of how well you can
perform and what what you know but more
important than that it gives you an
indication of what you don't know and
what you are incapable of so that's the
that's the diagnosis okay so take this
as a as the diagnosis of what you have
to do so people think like I have to
work hard do I have to work hard this in
like 10 hours 12 hours or if forget all
of those things these are arbitrary
arbitrary advices
what you have to actually work is that
give the mock test and and study the
things which you don't know this is so
very I mean clear-cut okay so there is
no philosophy needed there is no extra
motivation required for this you have
found out it's clear to you on that
piece of paper on whatever the the
online test that these are the concepts
that you don't know study them next time
make sure that you can answer this ok so
sometimes you don't need special kinds
of strategies or anything some sometimes
the most obvious things are just staring
at your face okay so these are the four
important tips first of all was the
leveling up okay step by step making
sure that every step is concrete second
was this uh not spending too much time
in your comfort zone then the coaching
Institute thing don't let them guide you
on their schedule you pick your own
schedule to ensure that you get the you
make the best use of the extra time that
you have given yourself in this drop
year and fourth of course is this mock
test okay so making sure that you never
ever make a mistake of of one thing
which you have stumbled on okay and I I
like this this fourth tip so much I'll
give you another thing is that they say
that
the best way to to kill your enemy is to
make him your friend so once you find
that a concept is your enemy because you
have not been able to score in it learn
it so well that it becomes your friend
okay all right now the scolding
okay
see
you are watching this video in your drop
Year all right so I don't know what you
want to call this is a motivational
video or what and there are some
motivational videos
in this wild zone of the internet
uh
what are you doing man
okay
what are you doing
see
you are trying to find motivation
outside of yourself
okay
you are motivated enough
you think that you you need motivation
right
you are motivated enough to go and
search for something on YouTube
and watch it maybe for 10 minutes 15
minutes something and then maybe it'll
automatically recommend you another
video will click on that you will watch
that okay lots of goody goody stuff very
motivational quotes very inspirational
quotes maybe you can you'll watch
something which uh which is from General
philosophy how to tackle hardships in
life and all those things what are you
doing what is this motivation
showtification business what is this
inspiration
all this is mithya okay all this is a
lie
there is no motivation there is no
inspiration
okay whatever is required is there
within you whatever is what is what is
actually required you know what to do
you just have to listen to
yourself in a very genuine fashion that
is just you your brain and the test
there is also the feeling that I need
some kind of an external motivation to
help me tackle society and and how I I
get to get to deal with the various
kinds of toxicity and the negativity
which people around me those
neighborhood uncles and aunties they
they keep pestering me sometimes even my
parents my siblings they say certain
things I need some external help to to
to to bolster me in this big battle
you don't require that okay let them say
let them say
why you why you why do you need extra
motivation for this why do you need some
kind of an external bolster for this you
need this because you do not have and
here I am giving a scolding you need
this because you do not have enough
faith in yourself you do not have enough
belief in yourself that's why you need
this extra extra
bolstered okay this extra support and
why do you not have this belief and why
do you not have this Faith because you
do not believe that you can tackle this
exam on your own
okay this is so so what is actually
lacking is preparation you improve your
preparation automatically you will see
that you will not need this extra
bolster this extra support
so that's why I'm saying all this
external motivation inspiration this is
all a lie okay the only truth is the
genuine nature of your preparation do
not lie to yourself
okay as long as you are honest with
yourself regarding your preparation you
can think you can have dreams and goals
and aspirations big big things but at
the end of the day it comes down to
business and you have to actually tackle
it at at its absolute truth value okay
you have to understand for yourself what
what is the genuine value the the
genuine level of your preparation and
how you can keep on leveling up in the
more you level up the more confidence
you'll have in yourself and that itself
will be the internal support which is
everything that you will require to
tackle all the negativity and the
toxicity that may be around you that's
it okay so stop going stop trying to
find out motivational videos if you are
if you are already motivated enough to
go and search for a motivational video
you are motivated enough to study okay
so stop this video anyway I have I'm
done speaking stop this video stop
watching this all this stupid thing
things
just go and level up your preparation
that's it okay so I wish you all the
very best thank you and I hope I'll be
able to see you placed in in an IIT or
the or the Institute of your choice next
year
go ahead